okay hi there welcome to another episode
of
science and technology q a for kids
and others and we seem to have all kinds
of interesting questions
saved up uh from um
uh from before let's see the first
question here from crunchy
oh this is not an easy question the
question is
why does the universe exist
and that is something i've been thinking
about quite a bit recently
i'm not sure how far i'm going to be
able to go here
on describing that i wrote a piece about
that question fairly recently
but let's let's try and understand the
nature of the question
why does the universe exist another way
to put it is why is there something
rather than nothing another thing we can
say so the first thing we can say is
can we make a model for the universe
can we make an abstract formal system
that describes how the universe works
can we for example make a
program which if you ran the program
it would simulate everything that
happens in the universe
well let's say we can be successful at
that we've got a program
which when we run it we'll reproduce
what the what the universe does
so it's like we're running a simulation
game and it is the universe so to speak
it it reproduces all of the physics of
the universe
it reproduces the sun and the planets
and black holes and
and everything about the universe the
program is reproducing that
so in other words we could tell the
program
with the program we could make an image
we can make a picture of you know
what does the night sky look like and
there will be a a picture on the
computer with pixels representing stars
and things like this
but the question is that's not the
universe that's
a simulation a model of the universe
that's
us representing the universe on a
computer
the question is why does the actual
universe exist
why is there why is that actualized
let's say we have that model
and that model would reproduce the
universe
the question is why is the universe with
actual
stuff like you know actual physical
things that we can pick up and do things
with and so on
why is that actually here
as opposed to just there being a
simulation model
of what's here okay that's the challenge
so first thing is to have a model that
does reproduce the universe
and we're getting quite close to that
with our physics project we know we
think
what at least the framework for that
model looks like
okay then but the question is given the
model
why is it actualized why is it turned
into the actual universe starting with a
big bang and doing everything the
universe did
okay this is where things get a little
complicated
so let's see where to how to do this
the first thing to realize
is that our experience of the universe
is well we are a part of the universe
we are experiencing the universe but we
are also part of the universe so to
speak
and so we're uh in in this simulation
that we're talking about
we are we are pieces of that we're
pieces of what's going on there
and so the question is we might say
for example i might look at the
simulation the simulation might have
a model of uh
you know a person i know in it
and i might be able to look at the
simulation and say
the person i know is behaving just like
i know they would behave
and of course i'm not inside that person
so i can't tell from the inside
whether that person feels that they're
really there
all i can tell is from the outside i can
see the simulation
and that person looks like they're doing
what the person
would actually do that i know in real
life so to speak
okay but but for me i'm like
i i actually exist and i'm not just
a simulation of me so to speak
okay how does this all unravel well
the key observation uh
let's see how best to get to this
um okay so let's go from a different
direction
let's say you have a model of the
universe
and you might say why is it that model
of the universe and not another model of
the universe
why is the why does the universe work
according to this particular model
you might say it's like the question of
why is there something rather than
nothing
why is there this particular thing
rather than something else
you might say there's got to be some
sort of uh
some sort of godlike figure who must
have picked
these are the rules for the universe
this is what i want to run
this is what will turn into the universe
i think there's a there's a nice kind of
um uh
version of that from a philosopher named
spinoza
from the 1600s i guess um
where he described the universe
as the thoughts of god actualized
so it's kind of like there are there's
sort of a logical thinking process
that's going on
and the universe in his picture of what
was happening
is those that sort of logic of thoughts
and the logic is what leads to laws of
physics and so on
and it's those being actualized that
make our universe
so okay so the the next question is why
is it
this universe and not another universe
okay
so in our models of physics one of the
things that happens is
that there can be uh given the structure
of the universe given a state of the
universe
there can be many different possible
states
which the universe goes into at the next
moment in time
and in fact there's this whole branching
and merging structure this whole
multi-way graph
of possible histories of the universe
that can develop
and one of the things that we realized
is that quantum mechanics
sort of a key piece of physics is the
result
of this kind of branching and merging of
histories of the universe
so in a sense there isn't a unique
history for the universe
there's not a unique set of things that
happen in the universe there are many
possibilities
and they're all happening and so one of
the questions then is well why do we
perceive
a single set of things to be happening
in the universe
and the answer which is a little bit
hard to understand
is well we are part of the universe so
in a sense
if the universe is going in these many
branches of history so are our brains
so it's kind of the story of how does a
branching brain
perceive a branching universe and it's
merely the fact that we have the idea
that the universe does a definite thing
that causes us
to sort of knit together those different
branches
of what of of how our brain is behaving
to say well actually the universe is
doing this definite thing
okay so it turns out you can go even
more extreme than that not only
does the universe follow a particular
rule but apply it in many different ways
so also the universe can actually follow
all possible rules
and in some sense i think the universe
is following all possible rules
now you might say how do you then
conclude anything
it's like if the universe can follow all
possible rules it's like
not everything every possible thing can
happen so how can you ever say anything
in science or otherwise
well that's not the way it works because
the point is
that as soon as you say all possible
rules can be followed
and it can be the case that
and you're starting from many different
possible states where you get to many
different possible states
you get this complicated network because
a
you can say you start from a state there
are two rules that apply
they lead to two different states then
there are several rules that apply there
and one of the things that can happen is
the states that you get to
by from those two different states
can merge and be the same state so what
you end up with is this complicated
entangled graph
of states that you get to by applying
different possible rules
and even when you're applying all
possible rules the thing you get
is not just a nothing it's a very
complicated v
structure with a very complicated thing
with very definite structure
and in a sense that is the universal
possible universes
that's that's the entangled version of
the histories
of all possible universes the they're
all tangled together
and so then the in a sense that
then it's not a question of well which
universe gets picked
it's all universes are getting picked
they all have these complicated
entangled histories
and so then the question is well if we
are
perceiving the universe if we are
observing what's going on
we are also part of this complicated
entangled
universal possible universes uh sort of
history of all possible universes
uh thing and what we realize
in the end is that it is
as as entities embedded in this
we perceive what's going on we
we can only perceive some small slice of
all these possible things that are
happening
because we are in a sense uh observers
who have only who are able to do only a
certain amount of computation
and so on we are only capable of
perceiving a small slice
of this sort of uh history of all
possible histories
uh object another way to look at it is
in physical space
we live at a particular place in the
universe
and it's a huge amount of effort that we
haven't been able to do to like travel
to a different galaxy or whatever else
to move around
in physical space we also live at a
particular point in what we call rule
space
the space of all possible ways of
perceiving the universe so to speak
we perceive the universe in very
particular ways there are an
infinite set of possible ways you could
perceive the universe
but we perceive it only in a particular
way so it's in a sense we're we're at a
particular place in physical space
we're also at a particular place in
rural space
and the thing to realize is the universe
that's out there in rural space
is this universe of all possible
histories and
no choice had to be made in producing
that the choice is
where in rural space do we happen to
live just like
where in physical space do we happen to
live and that determines the details of
our
experience and perception of the
universe so now the question is
uh why uh the original question said why
does the universe exist
well the answer is that this structure
that we get
from following sort of all possible
rules is
the is the inevitable structure that you
get
by following formal rules for things
so like you might define one plus
and then you say one plus one equals
define equals
define two it's inevitable given the
definitions of one and plus and equals
and two
that one plus one is equal to two that's
not something where you have to
actualize anything that is an inevitable
uh formal fact and so what ends up
happening is
that you realize that the set of all
possible formal facts
is and their consequences that sort of
computational consequences
is the thing that creates this object
that is this history of all possible
universes
and the fact that that there's no real
issue of
why that exists because it is a formal
fact
that that is a con that is a thing that
can be constructed formally just like
you can formally construct one plus one
equals two
you don't have to say i have these one
stone and another stone
and you put them together and it's two
stones so in a sense
the the question of sort of why the
universe exists
is this statement that in fact the
universe
exists because it is constructed from
these purely formal
objects which and it is all possible
formal objects
and so there's no oh we're picking this
particular one to exist
it's like all possible formal objects
and you can kind of construct any of
them
and then our perception of the universe
is based on
sort of living at this being
experiencing it from this one particular
uh point in this rule space
this is a complicated subject and i i i
hope that gives at least some flavor of
how one can answer that type of question
that one of the interesting consequences
is that insofar as the universe exists
according to this argument
so also mathematics exists and one might
think of mathematics as something where
you just decide i'm going to set up
certain rules for mathematics
i'm going to say x plus y equals y plus
x that's a rule that's an
axiom for mathematics and i'm going to
build mathematics up for maxims
and that's been for the last 100 um 30
years or so
that's been kind of the traditional view
of kind of what mathematics is
it's something where you pick a set of
axioms a set of
principles for how geometry works or
arithmetic or something like that
and you build up all the consequences of
that from those principles
what this realization about the universe
and its existence
implies is that there's actually an
object
that is not picking particular sets of
axioms
but it is an object that represents the
consequences of all possible axioms
and that in a sense mathematics as we
practice it
is really just looking at little tiny
corners and slices
of this object that represents all
conceivable mathematics
it's a somewhat different view of
mathematics and there are things that
one can imagine
are global features of this sort of
universal possible mathematics says
just as there are global features of the
physical universe
of all possible universes and those
global features turn out to be
laws of physics that we know like laws
of gravity
laws about quantum mechanics and so on
and so we don't yet know
what those corresponding sort of global
laws of the mathematics of all possible
mathematics will be like
but that's a thing while i'm actively
studying that right now
um don't yet have uh good answers to it
but um okay that was a that was a
pretty complicated set of set of ideas
so well here's a here's a
something a bit simpler to to answer um
baker asks when was the last time
i wasn't the smartest person in the room
um you know i don't know i i i'm not a
person who measures
who believes in kind of a linear scale
of
smartness so to speak i think the thing
that is always surprising to me
about all the different things i learn
about and all the different kinds of
things i do
is that there are people who are just
way better than i am
at doing one thing and way worse than i
am at doing something else
and so uh for example when it comes to
mathematics
there are many different kinds of ways
to think about mathematics
and so there are places where yeah you
know i'll understand something
and like many people i know will be like
i don't understand that i don't
understand that and i managed to
understand it
and there'll also be things where other
people
uh can just say oh yeah it's obvious
that's how it works and i'll be like
what on earth are you talking about i do
not understand that at all
so it's something where i think we
based on uh sort of some intrinsic
skills that people have and based on
what people have learnt
they're just very different things that
people are capable of figuring out and
not
i mean i i think sometimes sometimes the
challenge for people
just as a sort of a people development
kind of thing is to figure out what
kinds of things you actually
are particularly uncommonly good at
figuring out
because for many people there will be
things that they are uncommonly good at
figuring out
the question is can they can they figure
out what those things
are like you know some people might be
really good
like one of my kids um is uh she's
really good at
kind of spatial visualization of kind of
um
uh 3d objects and visualizing
what they're like and how they work i'm
useless of that
she happens to be a math graduate
student working on things related to
geometry so
that's a that's a good kind of match for
well she's really good at that
particular thing and
actually she's doing something which
makes use of that particular thing
um it's not uh the there are skills that
might be ones which
would have been really good to have 300
years ago in the development of
civilization then and
maybe it's not so obvious to apply them
to how to apply them today like
you might be well even even in my
lifetime you might be really good at
like reading maps
and understanding how sort of things
spatially relate to each other
and of course reading maps is i don't
know whether it's completely a lost
art in the world of gps but it's
definitely not as
prominently important as it perhaps once
was
of course there's still plenty of things
about visualizing sort of layouts of
things in space that are
still plenty important in lots of areas
so i think my
my experience tends to be uh you know if
you
if you kind of choose to to hang out
only with people who know about the same
kinds of things you know about
and you know one of the things that
happens to me
is that you know i've been studying lots
of kinds of things in science and
technology for
my whole life pretty much and i have a
pretty good memory so
i've kind of you know i've accumulated a
lot of experience
and so quite often it will be the case
if i'm kind of dealing with things where
i
i really know quite a bit about them
that yes i'll be in a situation where i
just remember oh i saw something like
that
30 years ago and so i just know the
answer immediately
cold because i like i've seen that
problem before i saw that 30 years ago
so i know the answer um and uh it's
if if one's confronted with something
new it's a question of can you
figure out sort of the new answer
and that's um that's something well i i
like that a lot
kind of figuring out from first
principles what's the answer to
something
and sometimes i find it uh very
disorienting when i i run into people
who are
who are good at as i sort of um
they're good at sort of operating at a
level where i don't understand the
pieces that are being put together
but they can come up with conclusions
even though
the pieces don't seem to be well
anchored into anything
and they can't even come up with correct
conclusions and for me i i tend to have
to build things up where i sort of
understand the foundations
then i go to the next level and the next
level and so on and it's been interested
in our physics project
there are different people who've been
working on sort of the front lines of
our physics project
and who think about things in different
ways and some of them
are much more in the kind of uh
the the the sort of the tortoise-like
approach of
slowly going from the foundations and
building up one layer on top of another
which is kind of the most common thing
for me
and there are others where they're kind
of going from these very abstract ideas
and being able to connect them together
and come up with conclusions
so um you know in my in my own life
i suppose one of the things that i
learned very early i happen to go to a
kindergarten
in oxford england where there are lots
of smart kids
and so i think i i am
from from the age of three i never
particularly thought of myself as the
smartest person in the room
because i probably wasn't in in in many
measures of these different kinds of uh
kinds of things um but
uh anyway a fun question a bit easier
than the why does the universe exist
question
all right so many more questions here um
uh
oh boy
um
okay there's a question here from simple
if all knowledge about physics was lost
which theory will be the most difficult
to rediscover
and why
well a good question i mean the things
we've been working on
with sort of our approach to fundamental
physics now
that i started about 30 years ago
a good test case for that is
would that theory have been found if
you know we hadn't worked on finding it
i think the answer is
i think it would have taken at least
another 50 years maybe 100 years
um i think it is uh
something where what's kind of happened
is that every field develops in a
certain direction
and it has certain sort of ideas that
seem like
they're self-evident and intrinsic to
the field
like in physics oh you build these
mathematical models and
you construct things in this way and so
on and so on and so on
and to get to the place that
leads to kind of our approach to
fundamental physics
you kind of have to go in a different
direction
and you kind of have to think about
things in terms of computation
uh there are there are you know i
haven't really cataloged it but i think
there are at least a dozen
kind of things that one used to believe
were true
that you have to realize aren't right to
get to this theory of physics that we
have
so in other words given where things
were
it's a complicated jump to get
to where things should be now
having said that once you understand
this fundamental theory of physics that
we've been developing
it turns out lots of things people have
been doing over the last 30 40 years
are building in in very much in this
direction but it would have taken a long
time
i think to get to the kind of clean
structure that we found in in this
theory
for fundamental physics that we that
we've developed
there are lots of things where it's like
well once you see that basic theory
you can start seeing oh this plug's in
here this is why this complicated
mathematical thing
works this particular way but it would
have been really hard to go from that
complicated mathematical thing
to this essentially much more simple
sounding
uh foundation for physics so that's one
where
you know i'm i'm seeing that in real
time it's like if we hadn't done this
how long would
it take would it would it have taken for
people to get to the same place
um i think that if we look at
a case that i think is quite analogous
which is the history of computation the
history of
ideas about the theory of computation
the the sort of the key moment in that
was probably the invention of turing
machines a little bit the invention of
lambda calculus but i think much more
the invention of turing machines
turing machines are these idealized
models of computers
invented in 1936 by alan turing
that are very concrete they talk about
you know you write down this
this line of of uh line of boxes and
each box
has a value in it and you have this head
that goes up and down the line of boxes
erasing
the values adding values and so on it's
very concrete description
while people have had things a little
bit that in the end turn out to be
equivalent to that
they'd had those well certainly for 16
years
at the time when turing machines were
invented but a whole collection of these
lambda calculus general recursive
functions
combinators post-production systems
just a whole bunch of different kinds of
things but
none of them they were all kind of
complicated and abstract and had a lot
of structure in them
which kind of didn't make it evident
what was really foundationally going on
and so it took the invention of kind of
this very concrete
idea of turing machines then you could
say well actually it's the same islamic
calculus
and it's the same as this and it's the
same as that and then you can build this
bigger theory on top of that
but it took those pieces to get to that
point
um and so i think that's um
uh uh you know in in in
um um it's one of these things where
there are these
there are these places where there's
clarity
that can be gotten but that clarity is
not easy to get
once you've built a deep and complicated
theory now the history of physics could
have been different for example i'm
i'm fond of thinking about if computers
had existed
in a long time ago how would the history
of science have been different like
uh the antikythera device which comes
from around well between
100 bc and 100 a.d it's this sort of
clockwork computer
used for uh computing astronomical
things and it's a fairly elaborate
mechanism
that existed in antiquity we have only
one example of such a thing there's only
one that was found
from a shipwreck that was discovered
around 1900
um and uh but you know i don't know how
common those things were in the ancient
world
and nobody kind of knew about the
tradition of making those things
from basically zero a.d up until about
1600 a.d when the ideas were reinvented
but let's say there had been many more
computer-like
things clockwork computers that had
existed in ancient times
and let's say they've been really common
everywhere would people have thought
about the development of science in a
different way
and perhaps they probably wouldn't have
had electronic computers but you don't
need electronic computers
to do computation i mean for example in
the 1840s
uh charles babbage and ada lovelace and
so on had conceptualized this
idea that you could make a purely
mechanical
you know cogs and rods and levers and so
on
computer that would be able to execute
programs um actually it's it's fun to
see
the question of whether these purely
mechanical computers where
instead of using electronics and
electricity to make a computer you
you're just using levers and gears and
so on
where's that useful today and there's
kind of a fun use that i ran across
a few years ago now which is if you want
to send a spacecraft to venus
the surface of venus is i don't know
what 300 degrees centigrade or something
very hot and um most things just melt
at that temperature and certainly
standard electronics can't operate at
that temperature
but so if you need a computer on the
surface of venus how are you going to
get it
well you can do something really exotic
you can you can run the clock back 150
years
and you can say let's use those
analytical engine techniques that uh
that charles babbage and ada lovelace
worked on and um uh and make a
mechanical computer for our spacecraft
for venus
but that's just sort of a fun thing but
you know how would the history of
science have been different
if computers had been common uh i think
for example our theory of physics would
have been invented
long before the theories of physics that
are based on elaborate kind of
mathematical ideas
um but uh uh you know we can't get to
rerun history and see that
um
let's see
there's a question from davao
um about wolf and alpha
and um saying yes we
well we don't use the idea of knowledge
graphs
is this kind of weird idea that kind of
came out of the early history of ai
that knowledge is somehow best
represented by a graph of what's related
to what
and yes some knowledge is representable
that way but that's not a great way to
represent all knowledge it's kind of a
silly way to represent all knowledge
um i think that the you know the history
of representing knowledge is an
interesting has an interesting history
i mean at some level our natural
language
is a representation of knowledge when we
start writing down our natural language
that's a way of
representing knowledge then there's sort
of more formalized ways of representing
knowledge one that people thought about
for quite a while is logic
you can say let's represent everything
by by making
logic statements particularly statements
in so-called predicate logic so
logic there are two fundamental kinds of
logic there's propositional logic
as described by aristotle and antiquity
and so on which is
he described in a slightly different way
but but in modern what terms we would
describe it as things like
um it is sunny today and it is
hot outside today and we could say it is
sunny today
um implies
i it is hot outside today and then we
could say
or it is raining today so we could say
it is sunny today or it is raining today
but both of those can't be true and we
can kind of make logical inferences
based on ands and ores of statements and
so on
and that's so-called propositional logic
and that's a
that's a kind of logic that is
ultimately what computers use
to to set up how their how their uh
their cpus operate is by
by doing sort of billions of logic
operations like that with ands and ors
and such like
um and um the uh that that's a sort of
a simple way to represent some kinds of
things in the world
then there's the idea of predicate logic
where instead of just saying it is
raining today or it is sunny today
you say uh for all
uh you know the famous one is
um you know all men are mortal socrates
as a man
therefore socrates is mortal and this
is starting to use sort of the idea of
these predicates
that say things like for all such and
such
or there exists a such and such so that
whatever
there exists a um i don't know
uh there exists on a line there exists a
point
between any two points online or
something i don't know what
you can you can say there exists
whatever so you can you can start to
build up
knowledge represented as for all you
could say something like
uh for all
um what's a good example
um of something that's real world
knowledge
uh for all countries you might say
there exists a capital city that's
probably not true
in fact i know it's not true um there's
somewhere there are multiple capital
cities and other such things but you
could you could try and start encoding
knowledge about the world
as in for all countries there exists a
capital city and so on
so people tried to do that in the early
history of artificial intelligence
people tried to encode knowledge
using logic it really worked very poorly
um as a practical matter then people had
the idea
let's just encode things in terms of
we've got these entities like a planet
we've got these properties
like oh i don't know has moons or
something
and we say let's just encode things in
terms of the sort of graph
or or a graph that says things like a
planet
you know the planet mercury is part of
the solar system
things like that and you know we can say
things like
uh such and such a person is
a part of this sports team
or there are other relate things in the
world that you can represent
pretty well in terms of these kinds of
uh
a thing as a part of another thing or a
thing has some property with respect to
another thing
but there's an awful lot of knowledge
that does not get represented that way
so for example
you're talking about planets you can say
mercury is a planet in the solar system
great
that's a a sort of a a fact about
mercury
but there's a lot like where is mercury
right now
what is the orbit of mercury how do you
work out the orbit of mercury what is
the
the distance between mercury and earth
right now that has nothing to do with
a quotes knowledge graph of
what is the relationship in terms of is
mercury does mercury have the property
of being a rocky planet is mercury a
part of the solar system and so on
so these kinds of models of knowledge
that are kind of static models where
they're
like this is a part of that this has
that property of that
for all this is it's a that those models
of knowledge
turn out to be quite limited and
the things we as a civilization know
particularly from the last 300 years
from a time when things like the
mathematical sciences have existed
now the computational sciences exist the
kinds of knowledge that we get
from that are not well represented by
this kind of static idea of a knowledge
graph yes
if you're trying to figure out you know
what products does a company have
and uh you know that might be
representable by just as a company
it has these products each product has
these components
et cetera et cetera et cetera that's
representable by a graph of connections
but in general
that's a very poor model of the
knowledge that we as a civilization have
accumulated
and in in building wolfman alpha our
goal has been to try and make the
knowledge that we as a civilization
have accumulated make it computable in
the sense that
we can readily if you ask a question
that can be answered on the base of that
knowledge we can compute the answer
and for that we've ended up using
kind of the full computational language
that we built in wolfram language
which is kind of a a full representation
of the kinds of things that can exist in
the world and so on and it goes
it's quite different from this just pure
graph of this is connected to that
now of course we have a lot of data that
is in the form of this is connected to
that
but that's not the whole story and um
uh it's um so so
ultimately the data that we get about
the world has to come from somewhere
and what we've done over the course of
the last 20 years
is to kind of go to the primary sources
and sometimes
compile them ourselves of data about the
world
and be able to sort of connect to those
primary sources of data
and it's a very difficult business
because
you really have to understand each kind
of data
in order to do a decent job of seeing
how that data should be connected to
other kinds of data and so on
and how you can compute things from that
data and it's
sort of a very different activity the
the activity have kind of sort of let
the crowd
curate data we have had a bunch of
volunteer curators and so on who've been
very helpful to us
but in general the let the crowd curate
data
tends to be a fairly poor solution for
many things
because it's like then you get all these
different things curated in all these
different ways
and what we need is something very
systematic that we can actually do
computations from
and so that tends to be our model now
you know things like wikipedia
has certainly uh you know quite a lot of
what's in there is nonsense
but um uh the you know and quite a lot
quite often what happens is
that there will be some primary source
of data and somebody will kind of a
little bit of a rip-off
take that source of data and sort of
spray it in different parts of wikipedia
and then people will say well actually i
know more about this particular part
i'm going to change that particular
thing well that means whatever
consistency there was
in those in those pieces of data that
have been put in different places
is no longer there so if you go and you
say i'm gonna
scrape all these things from wikipedia
you'll end up with something completely
inconsistent
and uh it's uh but wikipedia what it has
that's very interesting and very useful
is kind of folk information like you
know what is the
typical name by which this town is
called
by by locals so to speak and that won't
be the official name
that is in the government census and and
so on necessarily
it'll be a thing that sort of folk
information and that's the thing that's
very well collected
but it's something that is is almost
it's sort of
just the opposite problem from the
problem of making it very systematic
data
so uh let's see
uh there's a question from uh wick i
think kids and teenagers
they say are less and less interested in
mathematics
um what do you think is the reason for
this how would you change it
well i don't know some kids and
teenagers are interested in mathematics
but
yeah plenty are not and i'm afraid one
of the things that's tended to happen is
that the things that there's a sort of
mechanical kind of mathematics
that is do this calculation do that
calculation
that's a very convenient thing for
people to use as part of the education
process
because you can just say to a kid well
here are
here's a hundred math problems of this
kind go off and do these
and you'll learn some skill in doing
those but by the way you can also assess
easily how well did that kid do on those
math problems
it's it's a very sort of easy loop
that's kind of like a production line
for sort of learn these things and
uh be able to learn sort of the
mechanics of how to do them and then
test
what um uh you know whether whether you
were able to learn those and so on
and so the um
uh this is um
um this is kind of the um
uh this has been kind of a
you know public education and
mathematics has been going for 130 years
or something now
and um uh unfortunately the exercises
that are done haven't changed very much
over that period of time
in fact even if you look at the very
earliest calculus books
from like the 1730s you'll find some of
the same exercises there
that people have in calculus books today
of course a big change
over that period of time has been the
arrival of computers
and a lot of those kinds of things that
people would do mechanically
with mathematics we can now do instantly
and you know i've personally been
responsible for building
some of the technology that makes that
possible we can do them now with
computers with wealth and alpha with
with mathematica with wolfram language
and so on and um so then the question is
okay if you can do those things
automatically
then what can you then see in
mathematics what can you then
get to in mathematics and the answer is
you can get to some really interesting
things
not only can you do much richer deeper
mathematics itself and you can do some
experiments in mathematics
but also you can use mathematics because
you can use much more realistic
mathematics
to reach kind of things that relate to
our kind of everyday world
now you know does that mean it isn't
worth learning
the kind of the mechanics of how to do
mathematics it's
worth learning the mechanics of how to
do something precisely
whether mathematics and integrals in
calculus is the best thing to learn that
about
is not clear i think it's better to
learn that about writing computational
language
which is another thing that requires
sort of precision and kind of very
systematic thinking
to be able to do well it has the nice
feature that when you're writing
computational language
you get immediate feedback it's kind of
like well it worked or it didn't rather
than i hand in my homework and the
teacher says i did that algebra
correctly or not correctly
it's something where i can kind of
immediately see for myself that the
computer do what i intended it to do
it's also something where you get sort
of the leverage of all of
what we built in computational language
and so on and
you get to the point where you can
immediately connect with things about
the everyday world
so i think there's some
a uh the the fact that one of the things
people take away sometimes or quite
rather often
from learning math in school is oh i'm
not very good at doing this
oh it's really kind of boring that those
are
it's really kind of horrifying that
those are the things people take away
from their experience in mathematics
now it's certainly the case that not
everybody will be a mathematician not
everybody will get into
the kind of the fine details of the very
elegant results of mathematics the very
elegant
things that can be done in mathematics
but you don't get to see
any of that often in in sort of at the
ground level doing this mechanical stuff
which realistically can be done well by
computers today
so i tend to think that there are three
things that you get out of
kind of doing math think about three
um one of them is just learning how to
do something precisely
it could be writing computational
language writing programming languages
things like that
but some math it's good to learn
and it's good to know how to do
something systematically and precisely
one sort of exercise that i kind of have
have described about math and sort of
mathematical thinking
is somebody hands you a cube and they
say
label the corners of the cube how would
you label the corners of the cube
and the you know somebody might just say
well label this one
number one this one over here number two
number three
okay but be systematic think about that
systematically what will be some
systematic ways there isn't a right
answer to this
but how would you think about that
problem of labeling the corners of the
cube
if you're kind of used to doing
mathematical kinds of things and
thinking about things in a mathematical
way
you think about very systematic ways to
label the corners of that cube
rather than just well i do this one and
then this one oh i forgot about this one
let's put that one in next and it's
useful to know how to sort of
do things systematically like that think
systematically
another thing is that it's
useful to know what math can do what
kinds of
things sort of are
are accessible to math what kinds of
things might you be able to work out
using math even if the math is actually
being worked out on a computer
what kinds of things does mathematics
allow you to figure out
like if you say uh well
there are these two um
let's say you see a bunch of
recommendations for some product and
some are very good and some are very bad
and you're saying and you're comparing
two products and it's like
which product is better and you see this
whole range of different
uh scores for these two products how do
you compare those
again it's a question of thinking about
mathematically do you know about you
know means and medians and
and how do you compare distributions and
so on and that's kind of a
knowing what math is capable of i also
happen to think that math
is one of the great kind of both uh
intellectual
and aesthetic uh creations of our
civilization
and i think knowing something about sort
of its history and what has been
made possible in math is something
that's very worthwhile i mean it's just
like knowing
cultural history knowing other kinds of
things like that
the history of what's been created in
mathematics and some of the kind of
elegant ideas
that have been arisen in mathematics
even if you don't know in detail how to
apply them
i think it's just something that is part
of knowing about the culture
and and the and the development of our
civilization
um i am probably going to have to
disappear in a few moments here
um because i have um uh we are
uh we have just started um
uh we do a um
uh a bunch of educational programs in
the summer
and uh we have a summer school
for kind of grown-ups occasionally we
have high school students there but
usually it's kind of grown-ups
undergraduates graduate students
post-docs things like that
we have a science track a technology
track an education track
and a physics track and actually just
this next week we're starting week zero
of our physics track uh the main program
is three weeks the physics track has an
extra week at the beginning
we also have a high school summer camp
which starts in about two weeks that's a
two-week
camp um and we also have a middle school
camp
we just started this year and i am
supposed to go and do an event
for that in a few minutes and i'm kind
of
looking forward to that um and
that's a place where i actually get to
um
do these kinds of q a discussions and so
on where i know who i'm talking to
and i can actually tell the middle
school kids
whereas here i i kind of have a
suspicion that lots of you
are sophisticated adults which is great
um and
but i like to keep these q and a's if i
can
accessible to kids um and so that's
kind of um uh affecting which which
questions i'm i'm choosing to answer
here
and how i'm trying to answer them um but
uh
i think i will have to uh disappear for
today we've stored up a lot of
really interesting questions here um
which i will try and address
um at uh another time
um and uh questions
about um um
uh yeah so um
i think we should uh wrap up here for
now and i
um look forward to interacting with you
all again
on another episode of science and
technology
q a another week so
uh